Our discussion about the
future of the workforce
would not be complete without
an exploration of what impact
the current innovations
in technology will have,
specifically,
artificial intelligence.
Over the past three
years, there have
been significant
innovations in big data,
database architecture, and
artificial intelligence,
that are enabling new
business models and products.
In simplest terms,
the innovations
in artificial intelligence
are equipping algorithms
to make smarter decisions
about tasks and problems
that have, so far, been thought
only to be reserved for humans.
The accompanying innovations,
and cheapening of hardware,
that enables artificial
intelligence algorithms to read
and process incredibly
large data sets,
has motivated more
entrepreneurs,
and technologists, to innovate
with artificial intelligence.
Many think that the
implications for the workplace
will hurt workers.
Similar to how the Industrial
Revolution displaced
many workers through
the creation of tech
that was cheaper and overall
more efficient than people.
People believe that
AI will replace, not
just blue collar workers, but
also white collar workers.
However, the fact is that
the impact on workers
is under our control, the
control of entrepreneurs,
technologists, and
everyday citizens,
that are part of the workforce.
Business owners and
workers can harness
AI to augment human
intelligence in the workplace
to creatively improve decision
making instead of replacing it.
Here's Rob High, the CTO of IBM
Watson, one of the primary R&D
leaders in the AI space, making
this exact point at the 2016
MIT Technology Conference.
If we become experts
in everything,
we're experts and nothing.
And so the same
phenomenon occurs
within these cognitive
systems as well.
They can actually begin to
get a little bit confused
in how to ration--
this would be a good question.
So a couple points to
be made about that.
That said, because each
of these are distinct,
we can actually
set the system up
based on whatever is appropriate
for the application we're
trying to solve for.
For the case of oncology
treatment advice,
the goal is actually
about trying
to identify the best treatment
based on outcomes, based
on standard of care practices
and clinical expertise,
based on similarity of this
patient to other patients.
And all those can
contribute to help
Watson come back with an ordered
list of potential treatments.
But again, we're
not trying to make
the decision for the human.
We're not trying to
think for the human.
What we're trying to do is do
the research for the human,
so the human can then go
make the decision better.
In this case the doctor.
So we're not going take--
Watson doesn't make the
decision about what treatment
to give for the doctor.
It presents the doctor a set
of relevant treatments that
has been rationalized based
on all this other information,
at a speed that a doctor
could not do on their own,
including finding all
the literature that's
relevant to support
why they should believe
in that treatment or not.
So what specific
type of disruptions
can we expect AI to cause
for employers and employees?
Let's take a look at what David
Autor, a professor of economics
at MIT, said in the
Future of Work panel
at the Nobel Week
Dialogue of 2015.
In terms of employment,
as was said earlier,
people have been
worried for centuries
about displacement of labor.
And labor has been
vastly displaced.
In the start of the 20th
century, 40% of US employment
was on farms.
Now it's under 2%.
We had no idea what was coming.
But it came.
We find uses for ourselves.
And that's partly because
the technology augments us,
it doesn't just replace us.
It makes the rest of
what we do more valuable.
So, you know, I can make
more as an Uber driver
than as a rickshaw
driver, not just
because I'm in a rich world,
but because I have a tool that
makes me able to transport
people much faster
and further, and more
safely, and more comfortably,
in a given amount of time.
In many, many ways,
the tools we make
make our time more valuable.
Because there's always
some piece that we still
have to supply, and because
that becomes a scarce factor
that raises our labor value.
So there's a challenge--
So now let me say, but
let's say I'm wrong,
and that we're going to
be all replaced by robots.
That they can do all
the work we want.
Is that a problem?
Well, if it's a problem,
it's a very unusual
historical problem.
Most problems, economic
problems, societal problems,
are problems of
scarcity, of not having
enough of something,
enough food, enough power,
enough safety, enough shelter.
In addition to changing
the kinds of roles
that workers can take
on in the workplace,
AI-based innovation can also
impact social inequality,
for better or worse,
to be determined
by how we choose to behave.
For example, women
and people of color
are very under-represented among
technology entrepreneurs that
receive funding from
venture capitalists
for their enterprises.
If venture capital investment
goes towards a more diverse set
of entrepreneurs, then we
will see social inequality
improve positively.
Here's Amanda Kahlow,
CEO of 6Sense,
a predictive intelligence
platform for marketing
and sales, expanding on the
current under-representation,
based on her experiences.
The short answer is
yes, I feel supported.
But I do feel-- so I go
to a lot of CEO events
and sit on a panel like this.
The last, I was in Hawaii
just a little while ago.
250 CEOs, I was the only woman.
And in enterprise tech, I'm
less than 1% in this world.
And it's crazy.
And it doesn't feel right.
And I think it's
because we're missing
that confidence, and the
passion to go forward, and want
to dream big.
Do I feel supported by the men?
I think yes, I'm supported.
I think pretty much,
I feel very supported.
Especially my male co-founders
are ridiculously supportive.
And actually, I
think that they have
more faith and confidence
in me than I do myself,
which is amazing.
I think I have had
to, maybe, guide
and teach some of my
VCs and other people
in the world what's important.
And it's not always just about--
I think we were talking
earlier about the end
goal of the business, and
growing the business--
but creating a
sustainable company
is also about the
culture and the people.
And I think that what we're
missing in today's workforce
is putting an emphasis on that.
In addition to all of the great
technologies that we can do.
And that's the thing that
the women bring to the table.
I'm super proud of our lack
of attrition rate at 6Sense.
We don't have people
leave, and it's
because they feel
supported and heard,
and they can also be creative
and do amazing things
in the work that
we're providing.
But I think it's not intentional
when men aren't supporting.
I was actually
sitting on a plane
the other day talking
to a gentleman.
And he asked me what I did.
And I never come out and say,
I'm the CEO of this company.
I say I work for a
software company.
And I started talking about
the stuff that we're doing.
And then two hours into the
conversation, he's like, well,
what do you do there?
And he's like, are
you in marketing?
And I was like, no, I'm the CEO.
And he got up from his seat, and
he had this visceral reaction.
And he didn't mean to.
And then he sat down.
He's like, I'm so sorry, I
didn't mean to react like that.
And [? he ?] didn't intend to--
[LAUGHTER]
It was just a lack of filter
which we all have sometimes.
When he was realizing who I
was in the company-- and I
wear braids and pigtails,
and I don't always
dress the part of
something else.
I always struggle with being
my authentic woman self.
I want to maintain that while
dominating in the male world
that I'm in.
So I think there are
levels of education
that we can give others.
Thank you.
Income and social
inequality between genders
will not improve
unless we choose
to make fairer
decisions about who
gets opportunities
to create and run
companies in the tech industry.
If we do not actively
monitor our biases,
we will not be able
to take advantage
of this period of innovation
and wealth creation
towards a more equitable future.
There is also an
opportunity gap among people
for who gets to work within
companies in the tech industry.
Leila Janah, founder and CEO
of Sama Group, an organization
that lifts people out of poverty
by enabling them to do work
in the digital economy,
discusses this opportunity gap,
and how we can mitigate it.
Now interestingly,
traditionally,
in the informal sector,
if you're doing,
say construction
work, and you go
and you find your
job by standing
on the side of the road and
waiting for someone to hire you
as a labor contractor,
there is no such thing
as getting rewarded
for good work.
You might put in a
wonderful 10 hour shift,
but you will get no five
star rating on a website.
You go back to
zero the next day,
standing on the side of the
road waiting for your next job.
So I think that
technology actually
brings a lot more transparency
in areas like wages,
and reviews, and feedback, that
are very good for low income
workers.
And I'll say one
last thing on this,
which is that, David and I
were talking about this just
before the panel,
we so often assume
that technology has some kind
of morality built into it.
Technology, in
fact, is agnostic.
It's as agnostic as
roads, and waterways.
It's all about what
we do with technology.
We can choose to inject morality
into the technology we build.
We can choose to build systems
that enfranchise the poor.
Or we can choose not to.
But we're not victims of
technological progress.
It's not happening in a
way that we can't control.
At least until the singularity
happens, at which point
all bets are off.
[LAUGHTER]
The first is, job training
needs to completely change.
In the US, which is the best
example I know, it's abysmal.
We are still training people
for jobs that are disappearing
at an alarming rate.
We are not training them in
how to be entrepreneurial
and marketing themselves.
The skill that you need
for 21st century jobs
is marketing yourself.
If Kim Kardashian can
teach us anything,
it's probably only that.
But interestingly, all
of these new platforms
require you to be able
to set up a profile,
to choose the right kind of a
photograph that will attract
customers, to send
a follow up email,
to have customer service skills.
And you're absolutely right,
that many low income people--
And just to give you an idea of
how profound this is, in the US
we have one of our
centers which is
less than a mile from
the Facebook headquarters
in Silicon Valley,
in East Palo Alto.
Which is a very poor community.
And fully 25% of our incoming
class for one of our trainings
last year had people who had
zero internet access at home,
and no smartphone.
A mile from the Facebook campus.
So we can talk all we want
about how technology is going
to make everyone's lives
better, but the reality
is that many people
are disconnected.
And if you didn't grow up having
the internet at home, how can
you possibly understand
how to market yourself?
It's not easy to
be an autodidact,
and to learn how to teach
yourself things on YouTube,
if you didn't grow
up with the internet.
Advancements in technology
taking place right
now are incredibly exciting.
And we all stand to gain
from them as consumers.
However, as with other
periods of societal change,
we, citizens and
the government, have
to ensure that the opportunities
to launch, run, and work,
in these new enterprises is
made available to all members
of society.